hello everyone and welcome back to the
grand chester in paris it's the day one
of the Blitz still and it's a very nice
game between alexander bishop and the
leader of the tournament so far Maxime
Varsha holographic has the white pieces
and let's just check it out
without any further are doing with d4
Begley shook Knight to f6 c4 g6 and now
the early age for something quite
popular today Bishop to g7 nice to see
three and now b6 and here we have e for
with Knight to c6 already a new move in
this position which is not to be which
is not surprising due to the early
inclusion of h4 we have Knight GTE to
putting more defense to the d4 pawn and
now Knight to h5 making room for the for
the F pawn with Bishop to g5 here Grisha
casks Maxime does he maybe won't weaken
his Kings position by playing f6 Maxime
ignores it with castles and now Queen to
d2 perhaps with ideas of trading of the
dark square Bishop with f6 pushing the
bishop back and now although it's fine
to go Bishop h6 for the moment agree
sugary treats with Bishop to e3 with f5
further pushing the pawn with it
captures now nicely developing the
bishop with Bishop captures on f5 and
now f3 preparing g4 where white would
win material here as it attacks the
bishop and the night but here Maxime
says your king is still in the center
you have no time to push g4 and he plays
a 5 and now if g4 it's a complicated
line but I'm pretty sure I agree sugar
decided not to play it even without
calculating guess after G captures you
get ich after sandy for also with a
double attack
and now after Knight capture son before
you get bishop capture Sundy for Bishop
captures and mountain Knight 2 G 3
attacks the rook but now queenside
castle and here ok you do grab the rook
but you get the G captures on f5
Queen captures on h4 and now F captures
on g6 Knight captures on d4 with G
captures on h7 first King h8 and only
now Queen captures on d4 with check and
after this trade here you get this
endgame
black is on the exchange and white does
have an annoying past h7 pawn but it's
really another problem black should be
able to win this so after the five of
course Grichuk doesn't push any g4 with
d5 now attacking the night and not
nights the d4 so again you cannot push
g4 because of night captures on f3 are
checking the king and winning the Queen
so three shoot castles and now Knight
captures an e2 with Knight captures on
into and here
efore saying that okay g4 is not a
problem but agree should place it anyway
we'll have g4 now attacking the bishop
and night eek atrás on f3 g captures an
f5 f captures any - and now Bishop
captures an e2 and night to g3 now we
didn't attack on the rook and the bishop
but he really decides that well you can
just have that exchange F captures on g6
we have Knight captures on each one and
now rook captures on h1 not going for G
captures on h7 with check here agree she
can think that after after captures and
king to h8 that this would be a nice
shield in front of the black ink which
white will not be able to overcome so
here he says ok even if you capture I
can just push push h5 maybe open up the
H file this will be good for me
so of course Maxime doesn't capture we
have Queen to f6 and now h5 with rook 8
e8 and now comes even h6 and this is a
problem here here G captures on h7 with
check was best but gree shocked in his
full attack mode blunders and with h6
and the maximum takes advantage of it of
course but feel free to pause the video
and figure out why h6 is a blunder I'm
sure you all see it for those of you who
were able to do it congratulations you
are an excellent
Punisher of of you know bad moves and
for those of you who just want to enjoy
the show Queen captures and be to check
just remove the defender of the e3
bishop that's the idea Grisha captured
with Queen captures and now Bishop
Bishop captures again with check and now
if you capture then the rope could get
into the game with rook capture so
aggresive tries to hold on with King to
d2 now the fan
H captures and g6 and now Bishop to g4
agree shook is now done the exchange but
he still has the bishop pair and the
bishop care can be quite powerful this
Bishop is coming to e6 he's gonna push
the h7 point h1 at some point but still
if Maxime is able to activate the rooks
it's going to be a problem for Griffith
we have b6 by maksim and now Bishop to
e6 with check King to h7 and now comes a
for Maxime closes the the play on the
Queen side with a 5 and now King t2 with
Bishop to e5 now hoping to get better up
to f4 in with a nice double attack
either he's gonna trade dark square
Bishop or he's gonna create an attack
against the h6 pawn so Grisha prevents
this with rook to h4 now preventing
Bishop to f4 and Bishop back to c3 now
he wants to get this maneuver in to try
and trade dark square Bishop this way
and only then will he try and activate
his rooks look to h3 now with the threat
of maybe capturing on b6 and picking up
this Bishop here but trades are not not
good for white so it's hard to say
Bishop to b4 with Bishop to d4 and now
Bishop to c5 here saying ok either we
trade or I'm getting rook to f2 into the
game Grisha doesn't have a choice here
if he trades his just worse so Bishop to
g7 attacking the rook but it's not a
problem
rook you have to check King to d3 but at
least the two bishops now are preventing
the other look from entering the game
and here is a problem here the the best
way to go about it is rook to a2 and now
you're you're threatening rotate recheck
the trade of one pair of rooks
also maybe you're threatening to capture
on e4 okay for a moment the Bishop d7
maybe would be a problem but still
rotate you really a nice move for
progression but for Maxine but here Mac
simply looked at East 7 first and now
it's a problem probably he wanted to
play rook a to next and then for example
capture and then the d7 will not be an
issue but rookie 7 blunders the game for
Maxine I feel free to pause the video
and try to find how to punish Mac seems
rookie 7 with white while I give you a
couple of sec
for those of you who were able to do it
congratulations you are an excellent
player and for those of you who just
want to enjoy the show the movies Bishop
g8 with check now that is a nice move
after team captures you're getting h7
check and now you either have to run a
run away or if you capture the bishop
it's made into a chase queen king f7
rook h7 is made so unfortunately for
Maxime his rook to e7 blunders the game
but fortunately for Maxime Grichuk
missed rocked the g8 he played Bishop to
geez he played rook the g3 not sure why
but but he did so the game continues
with Bishop to b4 and now King's the e3
will Bush back to c5 check King to d3
and now maxime still not interested in
in any sort of Perpetual so he continues
c6 we have King 2c 3c capture Sundy 5c
captors and e5 and Bishop b4 check with
King to c4 and now Bishop to b2 putting
pressure on the undie h6 pond so of
course you don't want to allow something
like rook to h2 Grich who plays rook to
h3 again not allowing this move and
maybe he found the idea that he missed a
few moves ago and he's now ready to
execute it we look to f4 check by maksim
King the b5 and now rook tabby for check
King to c6 and here again best for
Maximus just hope for a perpetual here
maybe with Roxy for Ruby for Roxy for
room before or try to try to play some
super you know precise game but it's
hard as it's a blitz game and he has
very little time on the clock
he played Bishop to F sorry he played
Bishop to f4
probably just hoping hoping to trade off
the darks for bishops here but it
doesn't work here again feel free to
pause the video and now try to find the
move that wins for white
I'm only kidding is the same line that
we've already shown so congratulations
if you were paying attention
Bishop g8 check now we dick finally
plays it with King captures and now h7
so if you capture we already shown that
it's checkmate King f7 and now h8 Queen
so unfortunately for max
English now has a queen we have roof to
c4 check King to b5 group the c5 check
but now came to a6 it's not a problem
rook to e8 attacking the Queen but now
comes Queen to h7 and here Bishop says
I'm now threatening all sorts of nasty
discoveries with the bishop and there's
no square available for you King to move
if he played King d7 but it doesn't
escape the nasty discoveries Bishop to
e5 check by gree shook we have King the
d8 and now he just picks up the bishop
and it was in this position that
maxime beaugeois leader of the
tournament resigned at the game which is
really nice as well not nice but it's
really strange that you have such an
opportunity to go Bishop G check then
you don't see it and then the position
just you know comes up again after 10
moves so really just weird that
something like that can happen but it's
blitz you know anything can happen so
here he resigns he's just down too much
material and there are no tricks in the
position black is getting checkmated
very soon so that's the game I do hope
you enjoyed it I would like to thank
Chris Schneider for a contribution to my
channel and thank you a lot to really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here thank y'all
for watching and I will see you soon
continuing the coverage of this last day
of the blitz event in Paris continuing
the capablanca saga and of course
checking up on your suggestions even
this game was one of your suggestions so
thank you for that and don't forget to
update your organ master chess clock
thank you I will see you soon and have
an excellent rest of your day